hey what's going on folks I got some new
spoiler information for you today that
is hot off the press from the Watchers
on the wall Facebook page there has been
a casting update for Game of Thrones
season 7 and it appears that one
particular character that we have seen
around the set has now been confirmed
which character she will play a few
months ago there were several leaked
photos coming from the Game of Thrones
set in Northern Ireland and in those
photos there were a few new actors on
set that we weren't exactly sure who
they would be portraying there was a
little boy seen on set that some people
assumed would play one of the Karstark
remember children and some people even
thought that he may be portraying a
young Petyr Baelish during a flashback
scene but there was also another girl
seen on set
that appeared to be in her 20s with long
red hair who had first appeared to be
sawn to Starks body double but after
further investigation I think most of us
did think that she could potentially be
playing someone from one of the northern
houses well today it is confirmed
exactly who she will be playing Megan
Parkinsons agency updated her profile
and it states that she will be
portraying Elise Karstark
the Karstarks were one of the northern
houses that sided with Ramsay Bolton
during the Battle of the bastards
mainly because Robb Stark had executed
Rickard Karstark for murdering two of
the Lannister children so now that the
Starks have reclaimed Winterfell they're
going to have to decide what they're
going to do with the remaining
northerners who turn their backs on them
will John and Sansa be able to forgive
them or will they be punished for what
their parents have done now according to
the plot leaked this decision is going
to play a big role in the very first
episode during season 7 the plot leaked
states that during the first episode
Sean's and Jon will have an argument
about what to do with the northern
houses who betrayed them by fighting
with the Bolton's songs and Lyanna
Mormont want to give their lands to
loyal supporters but John refuses to
hold the Karstark a number of children
responsible Jon does it his way and
basically tells the others to deal with
it because he's not going to rule the
north the same way it's always been so
now that it's confirmed this will be one
of the Karstark children it does seem
like this scene could take place and we
already know how
Lyanna Mormont felt about the houses who
didn't answer the call when the Starks
needed them the most so I can definitely
see her having a major problem with
anyone associated what the Karstarks or
umbers but we also know that John is the
forgiving type and I can surely see him
giving the kids a break considering it
wasn't their decision this could be an
interesting plot line in the first
episode that could cause some serious
tension between John and those who
support him for now
so what do you guys think about this
information comment below and give me
your opinion on this now that we know
this girl will be playing a least
Karstark do you think we will see a
scene like this in the first episode and
what kind of problems do you foresee Jon
having if he does indeed allow those
children of the Karstark and numbers to
keep their land let me know what you
think about this let's discuss this down
in the comments thanks for watching guys
I always appreciate the support and I
will see you down in the comment section
bye